nevada is in the only state seeing
massive early voting lines more than 28
million people across the country
reportedly have already cast their
ballots so far according to some
estimates that's more than
six times the amount of ballots compared
to the same time
period four years ago in texas nearly
two million more people registered to
vote than in 2016
but as with past elections it's getting
a lot of attention in the state of
florida president trump won the swing
state
in 2016 by just under 113 000
votes but so far this year democrats
have turned in nearly 500 000 more
ballots
does the president casting doubt on the
integrity of mail-in ballots
do you think that's had some republicans
say let's wait until we can do it in
person
the president's false claims about uh
mail voting and questions about the
integrity of mail voting
have made only his own voters doubt that
very important option
another sign of the extra attention on
florida the candidates have spent close
to a combined 158 million dollars on
advertising in the sunshine state
with more money on the way